>>> THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
THIS SUNDAY.
WE BEGIN THIS HOUR WITH THE U.S.
TAKING A MAJOR STEP, A NEW STEP
TO SHORE UP THE CRITICALLY LOW
BABY FORMULA SUPPLY.
THE FIRST PALETS OF EMERGENCY
FORMULA ARRIVING VIA A U.S.
MILITARY PLANE A SHORT TIME AGO,
AND IS NOW GOING THROUGH
INSPECTION.
THE PRODUCT IS A SPECIALTY
FORMULA FOR INFANTS WHO ARE
INTOLERANT TO PROTEIN AND COW'S
MILK, AND WILL BE DISTRIBUTED TO
HOSPITALS, PHARMACIES, AND
DOCTOR'S OFFICES.
CNN'S POLO SAND VOL IS LIVE FOR
US.
THIS IS THE FIRST OF WHAT'S
EXPECTED TO BE MANY FORMULA
FLIGHTS.
>> IT IS.
AND IT'S MORE IMPORTANT NOW THAT
THE FORMULA WENT THROUGH THOSE
PACES.
THE INSPECTION, AND THE QUALITY
CONTROL PROCESS THAT ALL OF
THOSE IMPORTS GO THROUGH.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS WHAT
USUALLY TAKES PLACE IN WEEKS WAS
ONLY DONE IN ABOUT 72 HOURS.
THAT'S WITH MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES INVOLVED.
U.S. TRANSPORT COMMAND, FOR
EXAMPLE, ONE OF THE KEY AGENCIES
IN TRYING TO GET THAT BABY
FORMULA GERMANY TO THE U.S.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THIS PARTICULAR FORMULA, IT IS A
PRESCRIPTION PRODUCT THAT IS
HIGH POE ALLERGENIC.
IT BASICALLY IS MEANT TO GO TO
THE HARDEST HIT OF THE HARD HIT
FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DESPERATELY TRYING TO FIND THE
FORMULA THEY NEED FOR THEIR
CHILDREN.
THIS SPECIFIC FORMULA WILL GO
DIRECTLY TO HOSPITALS, AND TO
HOME HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
SO THAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
THIS IS NOT FORMULA THAT WILL BE
GOING TO THE STORE SHELVES, FOR
EXAMPLE.
HOWEVER, THERE IS HIGH HOPES
THAT THEY WILL BEGIN TO IMPORT
SOME OF THOSE PRODUCTS FROM
OVERSEAS AS THE U.S.-BASED
MANUFACTURING OPERATION FOR
THESE PRODUCTS BEGINS TO REV UP
ESSENTIALLY.
I WANT YOU TO HEAR DIRECTLY FROM
THE ACTING HEAD OF FEDEX.
ONE OF THE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT IS INVOLVED IN THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THIS THAT
OFFICIALS THERE ARE HOPING TO
POSSIBLY HAVE A FLIGHT AS EARLY
AS LATER THIS WEEK THAT WILL BE
A FORMULA THAT WILL ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF MOST PARENTS.
>> WELL, THIS IS HOT OFF THE
PRESSES, BUT WE'LL HAVE THE
FIRST ONE COMING IN WEDNESDAY.
THE FIRST ONE WE'RE DOING.
IT'S COMING FROM THE SAME PLACE
THIS CAME FROM, AN AIR FORCE
BASE IN GERMANY.
I BELIEVE IT'S COMING IN
INDIANAPOLIS.
I DON'T HAVE THE DETAILS YET.
>> SO THAT IS KEY HERE, FRED, AS
YOU HEAR FROM FEDEX OFFICIALS
THAT THEY HAVE HOPES OF BRINGING
IN SOME OF THAT FORMULA THAT
WILL HOPEFULLY ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF THE GENERAL POPULATION OF
PARENTINGS.
THIS FORMULA HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO IMPACT OR AT LEAST BENEFIT UP
TO 9,000 BABIES, POTENTIALLY UP
TO 18,000TODDLERS, BUT THOSE
WITH DIETA